hit with a big breaking report on all of
this she's been following the story from
the get-go our own Sarah Carter
investigative reporter Sarah we have an
update from last week
oh yeah absolutely Sean I'm here in
Montana I actually spent the day in
Great Falls and I drove all the way to
Lewistown here in Montana right near
malstrom Air Force Base and just to give
you the gravity of the situation how
dangerous this is and why the U.S
Commerce department is possibly
investigating along with the FBI
Maelstrom Air Force Base maintains 150
Minutemen 3 InterContinental
intercontinental ballistic missiles
silos out here we were able to pass by
some of those silos you can see them
from the road the problem is Sean is
that the telecommunication systems that
are out in this area are literally
honing in on Huawei Technologies meaning
Huawei Technologies has access to those
telecommunication devices and the fear
is is that the Chinese government does
too I also spoke with Congressman Matt
Rosendale earlier today and this is what
he had to say
we're here in Montana
we know now that the Commerce Department
as well as the FBI we believe there's
ongoing investigations right now into
Huawei Technologies near Maelstrom Air
Force Base
and it is right near our nuclear silos
what is your biggest concern right now
I'm very concerned again it goes back to
the monitoring if they can pick up
little pieces of data about when we have
movements where those movements are
going when it's taking place then that
gives them a very big advantage over our
own military because we have an arsenal
of icbms here that we need to protect
especially right now when we see all the
chaos that's taking place around the
world and what do we do now and and it's
very difficult this is where I was
saying earlier that it's always easier
to prohibit these things from taking
place than to unwind them it's the old
you can't get the toothpaste back in the
tube once it's once it's out and and
that is very difficult you can
eventually end up cleaning these things
up through our cyber security systems
and that type of work but it's a lot
more expensive and it's much more
difficult because you never know what
you missed until it rears its ugly head
and we we have a problem that that shows
up so I think that we need to again
start from the beginning know where we
are right now right let's go ahead and
make that a top priority remove that
equipment from the cell towers over the
next 30 days at the Chinese Communist
party has a problem with that there's a
Latin term that we use around here quite
often it's pound sand and we just tell
them that and and we make sure that our
country is secure
Sean Congressman Rosendale along with
Oklahoma governor
stit and others in lawmakers from
Washington D.C are saying that this is
the this is their ability to push them
out right now to get Huawei and the
Chinese government to uh to move out of
our telecommunication systems and the
only reason they've been able to do that
Sean is because under the Trump
Administration they've been able to
expand the ability of the Commerce
Department to investigate as well as the
FBI and as well as the FCC Sean all
right Sarah Carter great report thank
you